I think it was the ultimate aspiration I
think it still is actually male/female
black white gay straight anything is to
become a white a lost male that is sort
of the ideal American that is the
currency of a power and success in the
United States you think that's still
true right now I guarantee it yes we
really some form where do I see that I
see it when when I see rap stars dressed
like in Ralph Lauren it's just like the
the the accoutrement of wasp the wasp
heritage whether it's Brooks Brothers or
Lilly Pulitzer or whatever the or yachts
or Down East or Newport whatever it is
that still has the sheen of success and
power and even when people from the
south go to the white house there's just
this this transformation happens it just
is it's as close to the royal lineage of
America and you kind of want to be part
of that aristocracy and because we have
I do think an extremely socially mobile
culture still we're accumulating wealth
can put you at the top of power no
matter what your background is to you
then sort of want to make yourself
acceptable and that is those are the
qualities what however abstract they
become that we all value so that
resentment that's in the show between
the guys who went to Ivy League colleges
the guys who didn't go to college at all
you think that's still there in America
absolutely I think and as higher
education becomes more and more
privileged and more and more expensive
it's almost turned back in time to the
way it was it believed me there is still
a secret handshake you say that America
is still a mobile society but it is less
mobile than other places and one of the
things I wonder about think I agree with
that you don't agree with that no I
don't
I still think having lived in Los
Angeles where there is the true melting
pot of cultures of recent immigration I
think that people's attitude about who
the minorities are represented maybe
behind the times but if you look at how
for example Cambodian Americans have had
risen if you look at
the african-americans in the last you
know 50 years there is there is
tremendous prejudice but there is a a
still an idea that if you accumulate
wealth you will be listened to and
there's that you know that story that
you write about that mid-century story
born dirt-poor in the 30s and rising to
power you think that story is still
possible I know it's possible and I
think it's one of the only places in the
world where it's possible I am a a
reader of Piketty you were a reader
spica day yes and I do believe that
there has been some limitation to that
mobility I need to jump in did you
actually read that book I've read a lot
of that but well god bless you uh you
know what he's a great writer it's one
of these things where I don't even know
if if the if the research is good but he
is a great writer and it reads well in
translation how did he change what you
think he confirmed what I thought which
is that legislation to protect
inheritance in the last 50 years has
kept certain people from even buying
their way into power from accumulating
wealth and in again if you say it's a
meritocracy I didn't know it's gonna be
so political here but if you say it's a
meritocracy that is that you know as
long as we have money in politics as
long as we have money in higher
education
you know Harvard University has this
tremendous endowment but people still
have to pay to go to school their
intelligence can pop up anywhere and
having access to those things and
letting your children have access to
them and the story of coming here as an
immigrant and you know opening a liquor
store and then your children becoming
professionals doctors lawyers etc and
then their children becoming artists and
then their children being broken
becoming store owners again I mean if
you look at the the story of
korean-americans in Los Angeles I do
believe in that and I do believe even if
even if it's not rural poverty that
there is a way to there there is an
American story like that and I don't
think it's possible in other countries
there are very few places like the
United States where when you live in New
York City for a year and people ask you
where you're from you can say New York